MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome back
to 8.20, Special Relativity.
In this section, we want to
study space-time diagrams
a little bit more in detail,
and also define certain regions
in space-time diagrams.
So let's start again with
Alice's space-time diagram here
in which we plot or draw
Bob's space-time diagram.
The relative velocity difference
is 0.5 times the speed
of light, and that leads
to a gamma effect of 1.2.
We also plotted the world line
of light in here in yellow.
Light is the speed
of light equal to c.
I want to discuss
two specific events.
The first one here,
event number 1,
is the one where tA, the
time for Alice's [INAUDIBLE],,
and xB, the space for
Bob, is equal to 0.
So this event lies
on Bob's timeline.
If we read off the
time on Bob's clock,
we see it's 0.83, 1 over gamma.
And here, we can
immediately [? read of ?]
time dilation for this event.
Note that while xB Bob is equal
to 0, xA for Alice is not 0.
Similarly, we can look
at the second event here,
where we read off xA equals 1.
[INAUDIBLE] 1, in this
case, light year for Alice.
And so now we want to
investigate this length
in Bob's reference frame.
For him, time is equal to 0.
So tB equals 0.
We can immediately again
read off xB equals 0.83,
and that indicates
length contraction as
of the [INAUDIBLE].
Important to note here is
that those two, Alice and Bob,
will not agree when the time
and the measurement was made.
All right.
So let's zoom out
here a little bit
and look at another
space-time diagram.
So in this space-time
diagram, again, I drew light--
blurred lines, or
blurred lines for light--
in yellow.
And I [? wrote ?] a total
of 12 different events.
Now we want to
characterize those events.
And we want to characterize
them based on whether or not
they are time-like,
light-like, or space-like.
As time-like, we
define those events.
We have c squared, t
squared, minus x squared,
is greater than 0.
Light-like are those which are
like light in a blurred line.
[? ct, ?] c squared, t squared,
minus x squared, equal to 0.
And space-like, those
were c squared, t squared,
minus x squared, smaller than 0.
The first task is now to find
to which of those regions
the individual
events correspond.
And so again, stop
the video, and try
to figure out whether or not
you can find the solutions.
Because the solutions
are given here.
Time-like are
events 2, 5, and 6.
Light-like are the ones which
lay on the yellow lines.
1, 7, 4, and 9.
And space-like are
8, 12, 11, 10, and 2.
One of the things you can
find, if you are starting here
in the origin, and you're
going to correspond
to any event in the
future, you can only
do that if the
events are time-like.
If the events are
space-like, you
will not be able to correspond
between those two events.
That's one of the
ways to read this kind
of space-time diagram.
And in the next section,
in the next video,
we'll talk about causality,
meaning can a specific event
cause something to
happen, another event?
Again, this can only happen
if the events are actually
time-like.